going into Terminator dark feet you
might have some questions so yeah Carl
that's what everyone calls me is not to
worry we've prepared a crash course in
all things Terminator giving you a
rundown on ass films and letting you
know just what to expect from the latest
installment come with me if you want to
live first let's talk about what's gone
down so far starting with the Terminator
the film that got the ball rolling in
1984 a young waitress named Sarah Connor
is targeted by a hulking cyborg and
rescued by a young buck named Kyle who
explains that both he and her would-be
assassin are from the Year 2029 he goes
on to demonstrate that he can drive and
rattle off pages of exposition at the
same time alright listen the terminators
an infiltration units part man part
machine underneath it's a hyper high
combat chassis Kyle goes on to reveal
that in this far-flung future
Sarah's unborn son John is a warlord in
the fight against an army of killer
robots known somewhat artlessly as the
machines he further explains that he has
been sent to protect Sarah while the
robotic beefcake has been sent to kill
her over the course of the film
Sarah learns that Humanity is heading
towards nuclear annihilation in the near
future
in fact her son John will be the last
great hope of the human race by the end
of the Terminator Kyle has impregnated
Sarah after a steamy motel interlude and
he eventually sacrifices himself in the
hopes of destroying the Terminator it's
ultimately Sarah who kills the offending
machine with the help of a pneumatic
press
[Music]
and with that Sarah drives off into the
horizon then we arrive at Terminator 2
Judgment Day released in 1991 but said
in 1995 t2 sees Sara locked up in a
psych ward because she can't stop
talking about robots coming from the
future to tear our lives asunder
she's also prone to acting out her son
John bounces between foster homes until
one day a guy in a leather jacket saves
him from a police officer who can morph
into liquid metal it turns out leather
jacket guy is a reprogram Terminator
sent back in time by future John a
mission to save present John from
another robot who himself was sent back
in time to kill present job isn't
time-travel fun together John in the
Terminator rescue Sarah come with me if
you wanted to live the three of them
ultimately destroy the gloopy metal bad
guy with a combination of liquid
nitrogen and molten steel shortly
thereafter the good guy Terminator
descends into a vat of molten metal
hooray the world is saved or is it the
minds behind Terminator dark fate have
decided to ignore several installments
of the franchise in interviews director
Tim Miller has said the film will serve
as a direct sequel to the Terminator and
Terminator 2 Judgment Day so let's take
a quick look at what we're dishing here
Terminator 3 rise of the machines is out
of the picture and frankly that's ok
you're close now
it also means Judgment Day still hasn't
taken place in the upcoming film The
Terminator knew he tried to tell us
but I didn't want to hear it Terminator
Salvation doesn't concern us anymore
feel free to wipe it from your memory
bank if you haven't already and while
you're at it we're expecting to act like
Terminator Genisys never happened either
and frankly we can live with that I
won't allow this what are you gonna do
talk us to death you don't even have a
body oh and remember the TV show the
Sarah Connor Chronicles well go ahead
and forget that - at least when it comes
to the new film Terminator dark fate is
set a full twenty seven years after
Terminator 2 and it introduces us to a
dangerous new Terminator model called
rev 9 portrayed by Gabriel Luna he's the
most lethal Terminator ever created
and here's Grace a super soldier from
the film portrayed by Mackenzie Davis I
am human just enhanced Grace has been
sent back in time to protect Danny Ramos
played by Natalia Reyes she's a young
woman who's being relentlessly hunted by
rf9 come with me or you're dead minutes
30 seconds soon a certain fierce warrior
named Sarah Connor and your favorite
t800 enter the fray doing everything in
their power to save Danny from Rev 9
naturally the fate of the whole world is
in their hands if you don't make it
everybody dies one thing Terminator dark
fate shares with the first to James
Cameron movies it's rated R and that
hasn't been the case for a terminator
film in over 15 years as Cameron says
it's r-rated [ __ ] grin it's gritty it's
fast its intense in 2009 Terminator
Salvation became the first film in the
franchise to receive a pg-13 rating with
Terminator Genisys following suit in
2015 I know know why you cry but it's
something that can never do at least one
cast member is thrilled about the our
rating in a reddit AMA Arnold
Schwarzenegger revealed I was sick and
tired with the last time when the studio
decided to make it a pg-13 rating just
because they thought there were more
dollars in there I said guys you're so
stupid this is not Terminator the
babysitter type of thing no it's not but
wasn't that the plot to kindergarten cop
first I would like to just get to know
you this is Arnold Schwarzenegger fifth
appearance as an 800 series Terminator
or the sixth if you count the CGI Arnold
in Terminator Salvation but
Schwarzenegger character in Terminator
dark fate is apparently not the same
machine we came to fear in the
Terminator nor is he the hunk of metal
we came to love in t2 director Tim
Miller confirmed in an interview that
this is an all-new machine telling
comicbook.com imagine the rules that
original director James Cameron sat down
about what would happen with the
Terminator what they become they're a
learning machine they're a neural net
they just keep learning so the longer
you leave one around in our society the
more he learns about humanity and then
what does he become we have no idea but
Miller clearly isn't afraid to ask the
tough questions James Cameron's arguably
the only guy who ever got a terminator
movie just right but he hasn't been
involved in the Terminator film since
1991 well that changes with terminator
dark fate as deadline reports Cameron
wrote the story treatment and took a
hands on producer role and if audiences
respond positively to the new film it
sounds like there could be more
trees on the way Cameron told deadlines
we're looking at it as a three-film art
so there is a greater story there to be
told if we get fortunate enough to make
some money with dark fate we know
exactly where we can go with the
subsequent films here's hoping I'll be
back
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]